on this christmas eve very few books
celebrate the spirit of kindness and
generosity as much as a christmas carol
everybody knows how ebenezer scrooge
changes because of the events in the
charles dickens classic story what is
less well-known is how the book has
changed the celebration of christmas
itself changes that cross the atlantic
to england and are still with us today
mts tab takes us to london to find out
more
the bright lights of london are turned
all the way up during the holiday season
with the british capital's ancient
streets crammed full of shoppers buying
gifts for loved ones but few might
realize that it was the man who lived
here who inspired it all
charles dickens yes the legendary author
of the adventures of oliver twist great
expectations
and a christmas carol who were you then
the holiday classic that introduced the
world to ebenezer scrooge a miserly old
man who is visited by four ghosts on
christmas eve and of course
his famous scramble
[Applause]
hamburg hamburg
but what's less known is what inspired
the author to write it
dickens actually legendary british actor
simon callow who's adapted dickens for
screen and stage explains the tale
started out as a political pamphlet
highlighting the horrors of poverty in
industrial era victorian england then
suddenly had this inspiration he would
write not a piece about someone who was
poor but about someone who was rich
about a terrible miser someone who lived
entirely for money ebenezer ebenezer
scrooge the very same bob cratchit most
of us know scrooge gives up his selfish
ways it's mr applegate sir he's here to
speak to you about his
mortgage god bless us
everyone and lavishes a delectable
dinner on the family of his
long-suffering employee bob cratchit but
it's dickens's vivid descriptions of
delicious food holiday decorations and
goodwill to all men well when dickens
released together former curator of the
dickens museum louisa price says has
become something of a blueprint for how
christmas is celebrated over 170 years
after the author's death
what's really interesting about charles
dickens is we have to remember christmas
was not celebrated in the way that we do
now what dickens did with the carol and
his subsequent christmas writings was
really establish it
as a significant festival within the
country
and something that everyone would
celebrate the commercial appeal of a
christmas story was also not lost on
dickens one of the reasons that it's so
successful is simply because it's
seasonal you know and that was one of
the reasons he wrote it he wrote it
because he wanted it to be very
successful although dickens eventually
tired of his association with the
holiday a christmas carol's message of
redemption continues to be a gift that
keeps on giving what do you think he
would make of that the enduring legacy
of this
i don't think he'd be at all surprised
he was fully aware of the excellence of
his work
[Music]
so excellent christmas celebrations
today wouldn't be the same if it weren't
for charles dickens
for cbs warnings i'm impeached in london
thank you mts i like that not at all
surprised